hi I'm Brett Weinstein I'm an
evolutionary biologist my specialty is
evolutionary trade-offs I've studied the
relationship between Cancer and
senescence I've studied the evolution of
human morality I've studied the
relationship between species diversity
and latitude
and I also uh in my dissertation work
studied neo-tropical bats which are
obviously relevant to to covid in a
sense
it may not be obvious to people why you
would have an evolutionary biologist on
a panel like this
I'm obviously not an epidemiologist I'm
not a vaccinologist I'm not a doctor
but evolutionary biology is the linking
thread that connects all of the various
Fields involved in understanding the
covid pandemic and so it's the right
toolkit for wrestling the big picture
into clarity and I must tell you that
big picture is extremely disturbing
in fact I don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that all told the
decision-making surrounding covid
amounts to the largest blunder in human
history
um from the Fateful decision to search
out the ancestor of SARS cov2 in the
wild bring it into the lab
enhance its capacity to infect humans to
our inept and narrow response once that
virus had escaped into the wild we have
what is in effect an ongoing
self-inflicted wound worse still the
poor decision-making at the very
beginning of covet not acknowledging
that the virus was circulating and not
treating it with the best tools at our
disposal left us in a situation where we
effectively ran out the clock on the
very brief period of time in which we
might have driven the virus to
Extinction
so at this point we have millions
needlessly dead
we have trillions of dollars of wealth
that have been destroyed and the vital
systems that Humanity depends on have
been stressed to their very limit
but worse than that we have now made
this virus into a permanent fellow
traveler of humanity and what that means
is that as staggering as the cost that
we've already paid have been the cost
yet to come will certainly dwarf them
thank you I agree with uh Dr Weinstein
that our approach to this pandemic is
the biggest Public Health mistakes in
history the biggest Public Health Fiasco
in history
um
we basically
disregarded basic principles of Public
Health and in 2020 together with Jay
barashaya and Dr Sunita Gupta Oxford I
authored the great Bridal declaration
where we argued for a different approach
uh with focused better focused
protection on older high-risk people
while keeping schools open and not
locking down the rest of society it
turns out when with both Pfizer and
moderna we had a one in 800 risk of
serious Adverse Events of these are from
that list so now to understand what a
one in 800 means consider that our other
vaccines have about a one in a million
one in a million maybe two in a Million
this is not the same sort of safe this
is it one in 800 is disastrous if true
is the benefit outweigh these Harms in
this environment nobody has any idea
there's no way to know that because we
need a you need a study to figure that
out it's the only way but
we just keep recommending safe and
effective doesn't change it's not even a
scientific wording safe it's not safe
enough it's it's more of a campaign like
a campaign slogan or not even it's a
advertisement and that one in 800 number
that's for short-term risks that's
before we get to the things we don't yet
know about the things that might occur
two years down the road autoimmune
disorders Cancers and and the like so
that's a conservative number it's within
yeah the first two months the message
that was given to us by public health
authorities was not just inept it
actually went well beyond that it was
really the inverse of everything we
should have done and because it was uh
forced on us with this strong form of
coercion
um it it was widely accepted because
people didn't have a choice but what we
don't often talk about we do talk now
about the uh the Adverse Events for
example of these so-called vaccines but
what we don't talk about is the question
of what would have happened if we had
taken a different path and these
vaccines which I regard actually as a
technological achievement they're a
prototype that should never have been
injected into people in my opinion but
nonetheless they are impressive and they
have potential but by utilizing them in
the way we did we effectively turned the
world into a gain of function experiment
we gave this virus a evolutionary puzzle
that was very easy for it to solve
because the vaccines were so narrowly
targeted we effectively drove this
pathogen to diversify and there's a
question about how many variants we
would have faced if we had not done this
and had instead used repurposed drugs
for example to treat patients who needed
it and we will probably never know but
it is not clear that the harm is limited
to the people who are injured the harm
may be that the pandemic continues
because of this policy